this is the Salam alaikum peace be unto
you welcome to the Dean show in the
studio dr. how Tim and we're going to be
given some advice how to make sure your
children don't go astray what do you do
when you have so much influence trying
to influence them to doing bad but they
should be doing good how do you keep
them doing good because the Creator he
gave them to you an original goodness
not an original sin every child is born
pure how do you keep on pure and that's
what we're going to be answer here in
the Dean show with our guests when we
come back stay tuned Allah there's only
one word how mad is His Messenger oh la
la
o Allah there's only one but Jesus was
his messenger Allah no I did that maybe
it maybe it's just to break the ice
Salaam alaikum share my concern please
be with you thank you for joining us
here on the Dean show thank you for
inviting me that is the question now
people can go to the Dean show calm and
they can read a little bit more about
you your medical doctor PhD you've spent
so many years studying the way of life
that was revealed to all the messengers
of God including the last and final
messenger of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and all the messages that
preceded him Jesus Moses Noah Abraham
just to name a few Islam so now we want
to know the million-dollar question is
how do you keep the children from going
astray you see them joining gangs you
see them being promiscuous you see them
doing all sorts of mischief out there
emulating the hip-hop stars the actors
and actresses what do we do how do we
safeguard them from following an evil
path and keep them on a righteous path
let's start with this please you all
right won't say then this is the 1
million dollar question because it's
such a big question and the answer if we
if we try to be brief I think the answer
will have to be rely on Allah rely on
God because he is the one who can help
you no one else can help you even you
cannot help yourself if Allah does not
help you start early as the other advice
that is very crucial here and I would
say that it does not start from the day
the child's born it starts from the day
you you choose your partner who will be
the mother or the father of the child so
I think starting early is important
I think that you need to have a vision
for this unit which is called the family
that is you know one of the building
blocks of the Muslim society the family
so when you start to this corporation
you want to have a vision for this
corporation of the corporation also
should have a mission and the mission
should be an agreement with the mission
of the society the mission of the ulna
because it is one piece one unit and
that then the and the whole building so
I think that you have to be clear and
what is it that you want of this life
are we're getting married we have to
agree that this marriage is to help both
of us serve our mission in this life
which is to worship Allah and to be in
conformity with the way of Allah and the
the only collectively by the way has a
mission not only to worship allah IBN
conformity of the way of Allah doma
collectively has a mission to change the
world to be in conformity with a way of
Allah out of house of mercy how the Keen
listed it to to deliver this good to
everyone because every human being is
deserving of this good every human
beings deserving of being connected with
the Lord and created them they will
never find happiness otherwise so when
you reach out and you do this you're
actually being quite merciful and you're
being quiet kinda to to all humanity so
you have to have a vision when you start
the family and you have to have the
knowledge of how to have a family and
how to be a good husband and how to be a
good parent mother or father and what is
the what well are the Islamic principles
of raising a child or even an adult that
are based on for instance moderation
because sometimes people have extreme
expectations so unless your vision is
based on or your principles of raising
the child are based on moderation based
on
the centricity of which should have come
first the centricity of our relationship
with God you know as human beings it's
numb provides us a holistic therapy for
our hearts our minds our souls for
everything and all of this is dependent
on our relationship with Allah that is
the most important relationship that we
have to correct we have to rectify so
that we can be together our mind and
heart and spirit all of them can be
aligned together and aligned with the
will of the Lost Planet I'll at the
divine creator and then you will have to
understand also the reality the reality
that you're dealing with you have to
understand the what is it that you're
aspiring to and you have to understand
the child the reality of the child the
child himself and the circumstances that
surround the child the child himself
goes through stages you have to really
have some knowledge of the various
stages and how to tackle each stage for
the for instance for the first one or
two years of life this is a stage of
building trust trust versus mistrust the
child is building trust with the parent
absolutely yeah the child wants you know
the tall wants to know if the caretaker
you know the main caretaker is actually
a good caretaker or not and if the
caretaker is a good caretaker the child
will start to develop trust this is the
cycle odd the absolute ecology of the
child absolutely yeah you know so if the
child is crying because they are hungry
or because
you know because of some other
legitimate reason and you do not respond
to this the child will start to develop
mistrust and what about not not not too
you know because in this program we're
going to just hit some you've also you
you run an Islamic Academy and you run
some books so in this show we want to
just give some highlights and then
really get people because we can talk
about this is this is where you talk
about this for days now this is
interesting point because every parent
knows how the child will react they'll
from those years they'll throw tantrums
they'll be crying so what do you do do
you just ignore it this or some will
also turn to the timeout method is this
good or what do you do when they're when
they're crying like this and you'll tell
them no and they'll just start breaking
down for you know just for you may be
amplifying your voice a little bit so do
you tone it down what do you do in each
situation when you have to discipline
them because they're reaching for
something that might hurt them they
might do something that caused them harm
how do you handle this situation well it
goes on the age of the child you know
early on if the child is a little infant
you want to make sure that this world is
not hungry the child does not call the
child does not you know wet or dirty so
that's one user that yeah and then yeah
and then thereafter when the child is
throwing tantrums you want to make sure
that the child is mine pain because you
know the time could be simply in pain
and this is how they express their pain
if the child for instance has an ear
infection yeah and they have pain
they'll be fussy plus you know well if
they are fussy you want to really not
always blame it on misbehavior but maybe
there is there is a cause being high and
check it for pain how do you check if
you're not done you got to get them to
the doctor right away if they're what
are the symptoms what's your doctor also
you PA Tricia well if there is there are
manifestations of being sick you know a
little bit of fever decreased appetite
you know fuzziness is one of it but
you'll also have some other issues and
someone may be pulling down the ears I
want to be maybe haven't go later
they'll be pulling on their year yeah
tugging pulling gasps yeah so there will
be some hinter
indication but if it is basically
misbehavior than you want to also not
counter this by Miss behavior from your
end okay okay let's hold on there you
saw the tug another year you could do
some tugging on the ear listen to this
because we get some good advice from the
Sheikh we write back on the Dean show
eastbourne about 60 years ago in former
Yugoslavia today's Bosnia at the Second
World War and imagine today you have one
child feel so much it's important that
we realize that Islam is a gift so we
believe that in the teachings of Jesus
what is left there is truthfully I mean
he's the fries but the truth has been
mixed up with paganism and with nature
worship and so Islam has given you a
pure straightforward way of approaching
monotheism back here with dr. Haughton
check we're talking about and you also
pediatrician you're also an MD you're a
doctor you did see what you specialize
in when I'm talking to a car mechanic so
now okay so we got past okay the first
few years or the first what is it until
about two or one and a half where you
want to make sure they're fed take care
of them show mercy and always showing
mercy obviously but now those years what
do they call the terrible twos have you
heard anymore and the terrible twos
three where some parents are going out
of their mind the kids are jumping
biting you know screaming jumping on
here there everywhere and they can hurt
themselves throwing tantrums crying how
do you deal with this well before we
went on break you said don't so I can
remind you said don't counter it with
bad behavior yourself yeah yeah because
if you start to curse and if you start
to you know to beat the child for
instance for for some of those reasons I
think that this is Miss behavior don't
get on your part certainly this is a
two-year-old this is a three-year-old
now you need to try to figure out what's
happening and even if there is most
behavior on the part of the child you
have to understand that particularly now
we're talking about you know two three
four five six seven this this this stage
in the child's life
is a very crucial stage very important
stage from various aspects this is the
stage of autonomy the stage of
initiative the child wants to be
autonomous the child wants to sit his or
her limits so he will push to see you
know his limits is his impact on the
world is the child his influence after
you want to see how much you can push
you halfway absolutely because see this
is Perry this is real and and part of
this stage is to be egocentric and this
is not abnormal for the stage yeah so
you to be selfish to not certo is and to
do all of this part of the stage because
in this stage they want to test their
limits they want to see how far they can
go how much control they have over the
world around them shake just a side note
because you said now they're selfish
they're trying to you know not share
this that and the other some people
might argue that this is because of that
original sin that's how it's in their
nature just to go on a side note how do
we answer this because I've gotten this
argument for people what do you what do
we have to say about this well or do not
yet Muslims who are listening yeah well
what would make sense to say that I
heard this from chef Yusuf Estes and I
liked it very much he was saying that it
wouldn't make any sense to say to a
judge my you know my client is as guilty
as a newborn child it's you know it it
is natural for a human being to think of
a newborn child as innocent yes yeah yet
God would not actually make us
accountable for a sin that we've never
witnessed we were not part of by any
means so this is not fairness or justice
however God created the human being with
various inclinations and some of those
inclinations are good inclinations and
some of those inclinations are bad
inclinations now he did not force any
better inclinations on us but with in
our mail
there is the good inclination and there
is the bad inclination why they never
ledge then we've shown him the two ways
and part of our makeup also is that he
can go right and he can go left while
the child is not necessarily trying to
be wicked or evil but it is trying to
see how much control he has how would
how else would he know how much control
he has you know when when you start a
new job do people tell you usually you
know this is the you can do that you
cannot do that yeah and well he is here
in this world and he's seen a lot of
people around them and he's interacting
with them and he wants to know you know
this is father this is mother those are
my siblings those are people who come
every once in a while to our home you
know everybody has seems to have there
are certain dynamics here and everybody
seems to have different roles where is
my Road what's my role and what are my
limits so he wants to test them so that
is when you set limits because you will
not allow the child to hurt himself or
hurt others you gotta set listen
absolutely I got to be some disciplining
because you're not going to allow the
child to be a tyrant to grow up a tyrant
and sometimes people can do this by
spoiling the child by making them keep
in mind that children have a you know
one of the interesting phenomena in this
particular age group is a phenomenon
called animism and another one called
artificial ISM artificial ism is when
you feed everything's artificial
everything is man-made and animism is
when you feel that even the inanimate
objects you know the table can talk to
you and can be under your control and
the clouds and the buildings and so on
and so forth so those two different
phenomena are part of the psychological
growing of of the child so he feels that
he can be in control of everything and
that is not bad if you use it well if
you use it well if you give him room to
take the two taken
you know initiative if you give him a
room to show his leadership but to set
limits so that he knows that he's not
here alone and he knows that yes you can
forest far he can go as far as you want
but without compromising other people's
rights there are people who live with
you also in this universe and you do not
want to overstep the limit between you
and them so if you do this carefully but
you give the child enough room to
breathe enough room to feel that they
have a separate identity yeah there is
some level of autonomy give them a
chance to choose you know there are
tired sometimes they may have like a
very bad choice then then yeah you give
us activity how do you do that so are we
talk so the parents get a better idea
what age are we at now between where
we're now where we're to onward to honor
22 so so you're talking to them and
you'd give us a practice ample say you
know would you like to wear today and
you can do that well if absolutely what
would you know even with food you ask
everybody would you like to eat
somewhere so even as a child yeah what
absolutely you want to be doing this you
want to make them feel that you do not
control everything there is a lot
absolute dictatorship here nice but
there are limits I'm still a parent
don't lose that you know control so so
even if they don't understand you
they'll catch on that absolutely catch
on and they when they will know where
their limits are and they will know that
yes you may have the final word the
final worried about things but that's
just the nature of life not only between
the parent and the child but even in the
society there's got to be some hierarchy
you know after all someone will have to
make the decision the president in a
country or the chairman of the
department or you know the CEO of a
company there is a hierarchy someone
will have to make the decision so are
you always google gaga are you talking
to me like an adult you probably don't
you probably don't want to be talking to
them like
like a child because they want to feel
respect oh you know if I want feel
respect the tone maybe a little bit
different maybe a little more kind and
merciful but you you do not want to have
like a speech for adults and speech for
our children you want to speak to them
like adults with a different tone but
certainly you understand the limitations
of their logic because you know between
two to seven they may not be operational
yet you know in terms of their thinking
and it it may take them up to 10 or 11
years to have abstract operational
thinking what do you think about
timeouts you heard about the timeout
method when the child is now you know
going up in the cupboards breaking a
glass they didn't cut themselves what do
you do some hair just let all don't give
them room just go or sit them down
timeout have you heard of this method
yeah this time out time out is a
legitimate method because as much as you
can avoid physical punishment everything
I can make you avoid physical punishment
would be a good idea in fact the first
thing that you need to do is to actually
show them what is right because
oftentimes we get upset with them before
showing them you know what is right we
get upset when they do there is
something wrong when the Prophet SAW
solemn was sitting with ominous allama
and he was you know his hand was going
all over the dish and the Prophet peace
be upon him said to him Oh young boy
samilla say bismillah what could be a
manic eat with your right hand what
could be merry and eat from the other
side that's next to you so he did not
reprimand him he did not tell him this
is wrong this is called positive
reinforcement versus negative
reinforcement before you tell him what
what are you doing what's this mess tell
them what is right he said to him yahoo
lamb which is you know
endearing word you know all the young
boy Samuel Davis Malik will be immunity
to the right hand and eat from the side
that's next you teach them what's right
first right and force and reinforce good
habits before you do the negative
reinforcement teaching much right
enforce the good habit before you go
ahead and recommend we're going to take
a break and be right back here in the
Dean show if Eliza I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone if a las bombas i am not afraid to
stand alone i am not afraid to stand
alone i am not afraid to stand alone it
comes to you the truth and the attribute
of the one who created you that he's won
and alone running this universe that he
doesn't become Lord he doesn't die he
doesn't eat and go to the bathroom is
this is not God problem cares yeah it's
this doesn't make sense who was Jesus
worshipping Jesus recorded in the
Gospels despite all of the other issues
about the Gospels we put those aside
with the Saints mentioned there with
Jesus worship God
from hunger
back here with dr. Haughton and we're
trying to answer a million-dollar
question how do you make sure your kids
don't go straight and we're starting off
from the beginning because once the ship
sails and bye-bye is very difficult
isn't it so we're giving the audience
some advice from early young age how to
deal with the children okay so we talked
about the timeout method you get an
example from the sunnah of the last and
final messenger prophet muhammad peace
be upon him tell us now give us a more
practical let's paint a picture you know
the child is doing something bad and
then how would you go about talking to
him and correcting him and if you do a
timeout how long do you do it for a
minute two minutes and give us some some
examples please first of all you have to
ask yourself that I teach him to do it
right and if I taught him to do it right
did I remind them enough because a child
that is two years old may not remember
that I told him last month don't do this
or don't do that you need to really
repeat it several times and then
thereafter you want to be trying to
deter the child of the child that has
been taught and several times you try to
deter the child this is the stage of
negative reinforcement or various mode
modalities of punishment and it starts
with some emotional punishment very very
basically to turn your face away meaning
that you're upset and whenever something
can be corrected by just simple measures
you know big measures or enormous
measures are to be avoided to be
completely that's just with logic
dictates and that's the way of the
prophet salallahu sediment and teaching
us all things so set start with simple
measures and then try to escalate
withdraw the privileges also would be a
good idea to withdraw privileges would
be a good idea maybe that is not
undressed the timeout is actually was
role of privilege the privilege of being
able to go any
is restricted later on you know for an
older child to withdraw some other
privileges something that he cares about
and he said you know you're not going to
do this take it away now because take it
away because because you have done this
that's negative reinforcement and
negative reinforcement contain is also
test Kaleta escalade it based on the
what we call in Arabic Jordan while
German and jorma is the crime and the
Jeremy is the the size of the child you
know because you have to understand or
that the eighth at the age of the child
and the size so often times you have to
identify the size of the crime you know
because if you if you if you punish the
child for spinning milk on the carpet
for instance well does that need
punishment unless there has been
something I mean intentional about it no
there should be no punishment whatsoever
that would be take it taking revenge
that is not this a planet here because
your ear so hurt by you know expensive
carpet is now this or that so you're
dating a revenge for yourself you're not
discipline in your child and it is it
certainly is a very young befitting of
any Muslim to do this to take revenge
against the child because of something
that is not 3d a sin it's just a mistake
so you have to look at what they did and
you have to put in the right perspective
so abandoned their prayers may be worse
than much of what they do but but many
parents look at it from their own
perspective their own interest not from
the interest of the child and the
well-being of the child spiritual and
emotional every from from every aspect
so you want to look at the crime and you
want to look at the age of the child
timeout if you're three years old maybe
three minutes will be okay and
and then you have a mandatory for every
year because their attention span is
limited we're going to direct people I
heard you wrote a paper on this or a
book where can people go and we want to
do a part two to this you think you can
count on you that would be glad to
deliver greater dwelling God willing so
tell us now where can people go to
increase their knowledge on this topic
and in Islam in general tell us in this
last minute that we have well you can go
to my website and that's dr. Hatton labs
com drh ATM and had calm and the there
will be several articles on this they
can go also to MJ online in fact they
are better off going to NJ online
because they'll find some other articles
by other gets scholars it's MJ MJ online
org and then the they can continue their
education I think that every Muslim
needs to continue our education not only
to tackle a particular problem but just
to get the big picture because it is
important that you you're not using this
land to tackle a particular problem and
then you forget about Islam once it's
done ur you know no he you want to
really accept the religion and entirety
and don't be afraid to do that don't be
afraid to surrender and accepted so I
think that getting to know more would
bring you closer to Allah more
recognition will mean always more love
of Allah Spinoza nada because the more I
recognize his greatness is wisdom his
kindness his mercy the more you would
love him so don't be afraid of knowledge
and they can also go to where is this
place that they can go saturday
continuing education well I'm I'm the
Dean of sharia academy didn't go there
also to WWE area academy com okay thank
you very much madam is gorgeous thank
you we look forward to having back here
again on adding shop thing and thank you
for tuning in to another
episode of the Dean show what you have
you got to believe and do good deeds and
when you die what do you leave behind if
you leave behind the righteous child
that you're going to still keep them
eats coming in you're still going to be
getting rewarded for that but if your
child goes astray there goes your
investment so you got to put in the time
put into that time now so you can
benefit later and we are here trying to
help you develop that better
understanding through doing it God's Way
doing it a laws way sticking to the game
plan that game plant is Islam sticking
by the Koran the verbatim word of god
and the authentic tradition sayings
actions of the last and final message of
problem hon peace be upon his hadith so
continue to come back here every week to
the Dean show will have more exciting
shows on this topic and others and we'll
see you next time peace be unto you
he created the universe to him along the
heavens and the earth l11 he is the
first he's the owner impress me Ethan
his messengers to all his creatures on
the great danger Oh worshiping other
than Allah there is none greater
the creator